I'm Takamasa Shiba a I'm a producer for both the Dragon Dora series Banto Three. Because of
the fleece lining, there are 9 charts where you can ride the flying mother's dragon and fight with Ron
.  Rather than that,
the story of the uniqueness of the world view is the story of trying that anxiety and
sticking to the customer. I'm still fantasy
.  However, I can understand whether it is a monumental tower or that very strong way of saying this is fun,
but since the smell is
very strong and it has a world view and a story, I made this even more intense and 8 years ago.
I think that I have been experiencing new experiences with various budgets in those 8 years, but I
think that it is a way of standing like a form without experience
again, and this time the main character is poor.
However, as I decided this time, there is already a
Utautai mode and the return value is 3 cases,
but it is the reason why I did such a thing, unfortunately
Project One Two  It's an action.
Well, it's said to be an action in Japanese, so
it didn't come as a result, but it
's a high-speed action because I want to make a very high-quality option.
I want to specialize suddenly
Jim Sen Hen First of all, I think that is very characteristic of the world's first organization.
It's about the
story of Sakura,
and I think that's one of the important features of the game. It's
about the novel, but what was the intention
?  I've managed to answer it, but
when I'm playing a winter game, I came to the enemy's urban tissue, and
it was a good idea.  If
you don't have that character,
you can't know or like them even though they're standing or missing in the city,
so if that's the case, then the story behind them is in advance.  If
you put a participation that anyone can see for free on the browser well on the web, after reading it, if you
respond with that np, the same, for example, 10 minutes, the law is completely different.
That's why I understand that I'm saying this kind of thing. I
want to aim for the effect that the depth comes out as a game, or the depth comes out including the world view, so even if I use it like this in advance this time
I  It's 38, but I've been making this anxiety for 4 years
. It's an event 14 years ago from a tree. It's the
first time since then and I'm 14 years old by 10 years, so even if I focus on it at university, it's 23.  I
was a producer in the first or second year of my life. When
I look back on the work I want to see, it
starts from there and I have various unpleasant memories,
unpleasant memories, and unpleasant memories.  But
that's what it's called. Well, it's actually in the process of being a producer.
In short, hardware is prepared more
and more and jumps over it.  I think, in short, I've
been making that drucking spring all the time = Since it's after my producers Scepter,
I have various thoughts about Son, so I became a tree and tried it with this team for the first time in 8 years.
Well, if I thought that I could do it because I had strength, there
was a lot more than that, and it was
a work that suddenly raised me
, but now it's only a car series = this is always for me
There is something like that second part, and I changed it and looked back on it. It
's the same.
I'll talk about it on only four sides in the future.
I'm asked by everyone, so I have to answer properly
. Well, it's so sad in the market, but it's
shrinking.
I'd like to offer something to my customers.
It seems to be questionable, but it is very expensive and
there are many people who do not spend calories or money on the game, so there are users there properly for that value,
so
I specialized for those people properly.  I read that Drakkhen 3 is suitable for the title because I want to make a game like
this
, so I think that it will be a product that everyone was looking for.